SPEAKER: Yeah, welcome.
We have Sunniva Sorby joining
us today for a talk at Google.
I'll tell you a
little bit about her
and then we'll get
to her amazing story.
In 1993, as part of a historic
four-woman expedition,
Sunniva skied 67 days
across Antarctica
covering over 700
miles in winds that
topped 50 miles per hour in
60 degree below zero weather.
She pulled-- she and the other
women pulled 200-pound sleds,
and they were actually
the first women's team
to reach the South Pole in
a human-powered expedition
without the aid of sled
dogs or motorized vehicles.
Since then, she has
returned to Antarctica
over 50 times, completed
expeditions on Kilimanjaro
and the Greenland ice sheet.
She started an adventure
travel company called Red Door
Adventures to blend her love
of sharing different cultures
and also to create opportunities
for women in business.
And through this company,
she's created numerous trips
to Kilimanjaro and Patagonia.
Currently, she's
the global director
at Polar Latitudes, which
is an expedition cruise
company that operates two
cruise ships in Antarctica.
And I actually heard
Sunniva's tale firsthand
at a gathering some
time ago, and I
was truly inspired by
her tale of adversity
these women overcame,
which included setbacks
due to gender bias in addition
to the challenging and harsh
conditions of Antarctica.
So I'm excited to hear
more about her story today.
Join us welcoming Sunniva.
SUNNIVA SORBY: Thank you, James.
Wait, don't leave.
I, you know, every once in a
while you get to meet somebody
and you know they are salt
of the earth, really nice,
kind people, and that is you.
And this is a little
something for you
and your family to enjoy.
OK?
So thanks so much.
I really, I really appreciate
all the effort and energy
that went into me being here.
I'm Canadian, by the way.
I live up in Squamish
north of the border.
So if you ever want to come
visit, you're all welcome.
I'm very, very happy
to be here today.
And can you all hear
me in the back there?
Yep.
Good.
And I just want to
make sure that I
say hello to all of you that
are listening maybe or watching
somewhere else.
It's nice to have
you join me today.
I'm going to talk
about this expedition
not because I was part
of it, although I was.
I'm hoping that
through what I share,
you will feel like
the human potential
and the power of our
thoughts over anything
we choose to do in our life is
really the nugget, so to speak.
It's like that great
quote by Henry Ford,
"Whether you think you can or
you think you can't, you're
right."
Right?
So this expedition took
place in Antarctica.
And I don't know, has
anyone been there?
I'm not going to
assume otherwise.
No.
OK.
Sometimes a hand goes up in the
audience, so it's, you know,
it's random.
Antarctica is an
absolutely amazing place.
It's the only continent
in the world that's
not technically owned
by anyone, although it's
governed by the treaty.
It is the land of superlatives.
It's called the windiest,
highest, driest, loneliest
continent on the
face of the Earth,
and it is so because
it's so far away.
It takes you-- if you
were to fly from here,
like Mountain View,
LA, let's say,
or San Jose is the
closest airport.
You would fly to Buenos
Aires in Argentina,
and then you would take
another three-hour flight down
to Ushuaia, and from there
you would get on a ship.
We run two ships
down in Antarctica.
And it would take
you almost two days
to cross this very,
you can see it here,
this narrow body of
water between Argentina
and the Antarctic Peninsula.
It's called the Drake Passage.
And you can see around
Antarctica there
is nothing to stop the wind.
It's the largest-- all of the
body of waters in the world
circulate around the circumpolar
current in Antarctica.
So it's a very remote
place, and it's
a place that is not easy to get
to, even by plane or by ship.
But it's accessible today,
absolutely, with everybody.
It is a place where unlike-- and
I've never witnessed the Great
Wildebeest Migration,
but I would
imagine that to be an
incredible event, surreal event
to bear witness to.
They say that the
Antarctic continent
from one year to
the next doubles
in size because of the sea ice.
And we all know that
salt water freezes
at a temperature lower
than fresh water, yes?
So when the pack ice
starts to freeze,
Antarctica doubles in size.
Now this slide is showing
you how large it is.
It's, from one tip to the
other side of the continent,
it's 3,400 miles.
It's huge.
And even daunting
to think of skiing
across the Antarctic continent.
I mean, you can
read about it, you
can look at beautiful
pictures of the icebergs,
you can read the stories of
the early polar explorers,
but until you actually
go to Antarctica
and experience the
absolute beauty
through the light and
the ice and the magnitude
of this place, it
overwhelms you.
It really does.
So it's fair to say that
when I joined the expedition,
I read as much as I possibly
could about this place,
but it didn't prepare
me for the trip itself.
Of course, if we could take that
away from all of experiences,
none of us would travel, right?
That's the beauty of travel.
The South Pole is--
this is 90 degrees
south right here.
It's where the Earth
squeaks on its axis.
It's where all the lines
of latitude and longitude
converge.
And it's a surreal thing
to get to the South Pole
because you feel like, yes, it's
an incredible accomplishment
to get there, but you see
an actual South Pole Marker.
So you have to touch it, right?
You have to.
You don't lick that because
that's not a good thing.
It's like for those of us
who ski, not a good thing.
But when I got there and
saw the South Pole Marker--
it stands about this high--
there was a row of
South Pole Markers.
It's a little
defeating, you know,
to see a whole row of
South Pole Markers.
And that is because the
ice sheet moves somewhere
between 3 and 30 feet a year.
3 and 30 feet a year.
So if you were to build
a house-- don't do this--
if you were to build
a house down there,
it would move every year.
And eventually, it
would end up down
at the edge of the
Antarctic continent
where calving occurs,
where the glacier actually
starts to break off.
And we know that climate change
is a very big deal down there.
We're bearing witness
to changes in both
the Arctic and the Antarctic.
And it's very real down south.
I see a lot of calving
when I'm driving a Zodiac.
It's incredible.
So just to fast forward a little
bit about early exploration
because you know, 82 years
after the first team of men
reached the South Pole,
we did our expedition.
In our life, that's
not a long time really.
But it's amazing it
took 82 years for women
to even conceive of the idea
of going down to Antarctica.
And I can tell you that we had
a lot of people look at us.
I'm the tallest of the four of
us at 5' 6" or whatever I am,
and the smallest was Anne
Dal Vera, she's 5' 2".
So this is really a story not
about Sunniva Sorby or Anne Dal
Vera or Ann Bancroft
or Sue Giller.
This story about the
American Women's Expedition
is really about the
power of belief.
Not just individual,
but how important
it is for us to support each
other in our efforts, you know?
And the dreams start
when we're small.
When I was 10 years old, I
dreamt of going to the moon.
I don't know why, but I
So what did I do?
I wrote a letter to NASA, and
I got a nice form letter back
saying, stay in school.
So I did.
And the important
part of that, for me,
was that my dream
wasn't squashed.
And I'll tell you that skiing
across the Antarctic continent
and experiencing
the polar ice cap
was very much like what I
imagined the moon to look like.
So sometimes you
think you're going
to walk through a red door
and that's that one dream,
but sometimes it's blue.
So we have to stay awake,
you know, for our ride
and be open to the very
different ways things
get presented to us.
So here we are at the South
Pole, minus 76 degrees,
and we pay tribute
to Amundsen, who
reached the South Pole first.
He was a Norwegian, and he was
very efficient in his logistics
and planning, very
successful with sled dogs.
Arrived there a full month
before the infamous Robert
Falcon Scott expedition.
Has anyone heard
of these stories?
Yeah?
They're fascinating stories
because not only do they
dig into the human spirit and
what we're capable of doing,
but it's a story
about how, you know,
Robert Scott, for example,
they get to the South Pole
and they find a tent.
And then they find a
Norwegian flag waving proudly
in the wind.
And there's a letter
inside for Scott.
And then there's also a
letter for the King of Norway.
So it was a bittersweet
thing for Scott's party
to arrive at the
South Pole defeated.
They didn't get there first.
And they got there and they
were so badly frostbitten,
they were very, very
hungry, and they were just,
quite frankly, their spirits
were completely squashed
because of Amundsen
getting there before.
So they made the trek from the
South Pole back to their base,
past McMurdo where
the Ross Sea is,
the other side of Antarctica.
And they never made it.
It's a very sad story
because the five of them--
and you can see the sad
looks on their faces here--
but the five of them didn't
know how close they were
to a resupply of food and fuel.
They died at 18 miles.
And those of you who ride a
bike or we drive a car, 18 miles
is nothing.
But in the world of this, 18
miles is an absolute eternity.
We skied between 10
and 14 miles every day.
That was our day.
So 18 miles for them,
they didn't know this,
they didn't have GPSes, they
didn't use the same equipment
that we have today.
So that was an eternity.
They were in their
tents, and it was
all they could do actually
to just keep themselves warm.
And one of the men,
trying to retain
a certain sense of honor,
walks outside the tent,
and he uses these words--
I am going outside and
I shall be some time.
And he walked and
he walked and he
walked, never to be seen again.
Another one of the party of
five fell into a crevasse,
and they lost him.
And the other three were
found frozen in their tents
the following spring when
a search party came out
to find them.
And then Scott's last words with
his pen were, for God's sake,
take care of our people.
It's a story-- there's
been hugely debated,
these particular two
various expeditions.
They get compared a lot.
The Norwegians were
far more efficient
than the British team.
But it's really a story of
what we're capable of doing
and how planning is absolutely
essential to success, right?
But nothing-- I mean,
you can plan and prepare
all you want for
a trip like this,
but then stuff
happens on the inside.
And we all know
what that's like.
It's the experience
of it, right?
So here we are in Punta Arenas.
We actually flew to
Punta Arenas, Chile.
And I call this a
bad hair day in Punta
because our hair is like, woo.
It's always windy there.
And we would leave Punta Arenas
and fly eight hours to a place
at 80 degrees south-- hi--
at 80 degrees south where
there was a base there.
And that base would--
we with board a Twin Otter and
fly from there to our start
at the edge of the
Ronne Ice Shelf.
We couldn't leave for two
full weeks from Punta Arenas
because over the Transantarctic
Mountains there was a shadow,
and the pilot needs to
leave early in the morning
to be able to avoid the shadow
that this mountain range casts
on the blue ice runway.
Two weeks we waited.
We all know what it's like
to be delayed with a flight
or something like
that for an hour
or maybe half a day or a day.
It's kind of an inconvenience.
Imagine being delayed two weeks.
The worst part about
that was the anxiety
that was building up.
And it was also bad for
us because you start to--
we train.
You know, we're training
really hard for these trips,
and we're trying to eat
as much as possible.
That was a good thing actually.
We ate like crazy
for those two weeks.
And we stayed, you know, tried
to stay in shape by running.
And we also got to know
some of the other expedition
members that were down there.
There was a team from England,
and it was Sir Ranulph Fiennes
and Mike Stroud.
I don't know if any of you've
heard of that expedition.
But they were going to
do a study on starvation.
Doesn't that sound fun?
They were going to
see how far can we
go physically,
emotionally, mentally,
spiritually, how far can
we go before we actually
starve ourselves to death.
They wanted to find out,
you know, that absolute edge
of what's possible.
And they did.
They were actually, they were
taking muscle tissue samples
from their thighs for
some of the study.
And they were hailed as heroes.
They were found-- they
looked more dead than alive
when they were picked up.
They were 10 days away
from being very successful.
But they were on the
cover of "Time" magazine
when they got back and
hailed as heroes for this.
We, as a group of
four women-- you know,
women had never tried this
before-- we were extremely
careful about how we presented
what we were doing to the world
because we wanted to
go as a team of four
and come back as a team of four.
We wanted to ski all the way
across the Antarctic continent
from the edge of the Ronne Ice
Shelf, which you see there--
and we got a nice letter from
Edith Ronne; that ice shelf is
named after her--
and we wanted to go
to the South Pole
and then from
there go to McMurdo
and catch the very last cruise
ship home, which was February
14, Valentine's Day.
Motivation, you know?
Everything down there is a
little mathematical equation
on how many miles you do
every day, how much food you
bring every day, 2
pounds per person a day.
6,000 to 7,000 calories
is what we ate a lot.
And a large
percentage of our diet
was actually fat
because we need to stay
insulated from the cold.
So our goal was
to ski all the way
across the Antarctic continent.
I'm not here to talk about that
because that didn't happen.
We made it to the South Pole.
The reason for that is losing
two weeks in the beginning
to bad weather, and also,
I got very, very sick.
I had bronchitis
for over 45 days.
I had tendinitis in both feet.
And I mean, I look
back on this trip
and sometimes I'm not sure
how in the world I did it.
I clearly was not alone,
if you know what I mean.
So our mantra was,
four to the pole.
When all these setbacks and all
these things were happening,
it was, no, not two people
will go to the South Pole
and call that a success.
It will be the four of us.
Our goal was to also
pull all of our weight.
We had 200 pounds in a sled
that was about 6 feet long.
And you look at me and we can
look at anybody and go, what?
You've pulled a 200-pound sled?
Or, you've skied down Mt.
Rainier?
You know?
We're amazing people.
We are amazing when we
put our minds to it.
I'm not sure how
we did this uphill.
We start at 3,000 feet and
we ski up to the South Pole,
which is 9,300 feet.
I can tell you that
momentum is everything.
Do you know what I mean?
You don't stop, you go.
You do a little--
one breath, one pole
plant, one tug of the sled,
and then you've got the next
step, and you just repeat.
You press repeat,
repeat, repeat.
It's not like eating the big
steak at once or something.
It's taking small bites.
So you see heel
lifters on our skis.
That was really important.
So we were elevated
and we were always
move-- we were
always like, leaning
at a little bit of
an angle like that.
So we could actually
pull the sled.
It was very, very hard.
And in there was everything
we needed, from food
and white gas, fuel to cook.
2 pounds per person per day.
You look at one of those
bags and it was 32 pounds.
So it would be, it would
be, excuse me, yeah,
it would be 32
pounds in one bag.
That's for two women
for eight days.
And every eight days, we
rotated a new tent partner.
Do you think that's
kind of important?
Super important because
after eight days and you're
in a tent with someone, you
know everything about them.
You know way too
much about them.
And you need a little
bit of a break.
So it was a strategic
decision on our part.
So we've got everything.
We've got-- all the
food gets prepackaged.
We had kids, we had so many
children follow our project,
and they signed little
notes, and they put them
in the food bag.
So we never know what message we
were getting when we opened up
a new bag, and just
the different ways
that support came to us.
Our project cost
a million dollars,
which today is nothing.
Well, maybe it is.
It is, actually.
But we didn't have
one corporate sponsor
that signed on board to
our expedition, not one.
I gave a presentation last
week and a guy said, you know,
if you did this, if you
did this expedition today,
you would all be millionaires.
And I'm not a millionaire,
but I do feel very rich inside
if you know what I mean.
And I think that
counts for a lot.
So a million dollar expedition,
not one corporate sponsor
came on board.
We had Nike and L'Oreal
that were thinking about it,
but they didn't join.
So we raised money from
people like yourselves.
The average donation was $25.
We had money-- we
had a dollar that
was sent all the way from
Germany to the headquarters
in Minnesota with
a note saying, this
is the only American
money I have.
But-- you know?
But it was like, that
was so meaningful for us.
So we raised $600,000 like that.
Selling T-shirts, you
know, selling our souls,
traveling around
doing presentations.
And the extra $400,000 we
raised when we got back.
And it took us five years
to raise that extra $400,000
when we got back.
So it's an incredible story
of just the power of people,
you know?
And you're, at
Google, you're all
about connecting things and
people and the community,
and I love what you
have going on here.
It's absolutely incredible.
And I think that
cohesiveness and, you know,
being connected with
one another is so key.
And for us, it really was
the fuel for our expedition.
On one day-- and you
know, as four women,
we all had our
cycles down there.
And on-- actually,
after one month we
were all timed together.
That's kind of scary, four
women who were on their cycles
at the same time.
We were like cats, you know?
It kind of-- it was
pretty interesting.
But Ann Bancroft, who I was
tenting with at the time,
wasn't feeling very well.
And after a day of the
sled and the harness
tugging at her stomach, it
was really, really hard.
So I said, I'm going
to make dinner tonight.
And we did rotate who would
cook breakfast and dinner.
And I made her a meal and
it was macaroni and cheese.
I mean, who goes wrong
with mac and cheese, right?
So simple.
You've got the-- we know.
It's like butter, the noodles,
cheese powder, and some milk,
right?
Do you do it differently?
No, it's so easy.
So I grab-- I wasn't part of
the, you know, all of the bags
that we had to put into
various 32-pound stuff sacks.
So I grabbed what I thought
was the cheese powder
and I mixed it in with the
macaroni and the butter,
lots of butter, lots of butter.
And Ann takes a bite of this and
kind of whips her head around
and looks at me and she goes,
what did you put in here?
And I'm looking at
her and I take a bite
and I thought, wow,
this is really awful.
This was awful.
And I realized that
I mixed, instead
of cheese powder, orange
drink with the macaroni
and the butter.
Don't do that at home, OK?
It was so awful.
And the worst part
for us is we had
to eat every single
bit of it because that
was our ration for the night.
So you've got to be very
careful who you're tenting with
and who's cooking, number one.
Another goal that
we had in addition
to pulling our own weight
was to communicate with kids.
And it's not done the
same way today, of course.
We had a 30-pound
military radio that we
used on this expedition.
That's heavy.
30-pound military radio.
We set up skis and ski
poles and hung a dipole
across the skis
and the poles so we
could communicate in
the direction of Patriot
Hills, which was--
there's a base
there still today.
If you wanted to go
down to Antarctica
and photograph the emperor
penguins or climb Mt.
Vinson or ski to the South Pole,
you would go to Patriot Hills.
It's 80 degrees south.
And that's where we were
communicating every three
nights at 7 o'clock.
That was our sched time.
Our call sign was AWE--
alpha whiskey echo,
alpha whiskey echo.
So we would call
into Patriot Hills
and we would let them know
where we were, how we were,
how our food was,
how our fuel was,
and anything else to report out.
It was all one way.
Well, two way with them,
but pretty much one way.
We had no communication
with the outside world.
Doesn't that seem
absolutely foreign today?
I mean, on a trip
today we would be
able to take like a handheld
iridium satellite phone.
We wouldn't-- and we could talk.
We could say we could, we
could order pizza if we wanted
to-- which I tried on Greenland,
but they didn't deliver
Domino's.
Say they deliver
anywhere, but they don't.
I did that, and
I went and talked
to the manager when I
came back to San Diego.
But it's kind of funny.
So communication for us
to the outside world,
we had 100,000 kids
followed us with a map
that National Geographic
donated, and pushpins on a map.
There was no internet.
This is 1992, '93.
And I still, I mean, I really
do enjoy sharing this story
because it's about the absolute
simplicity around how we
can move around in the world.
This expedition was maybe
too far ahead of its time,
if you know what I mean.
Maybe-- we were the first
to do it and the first
to succeed arriving
at the South Pole,
but I wonder in retrospect,
with the internet, what that
would have done to our trip.
We had no way of
knowing how people were.
And that was actually
sometimes disconcerting.
We were also doing research
on our physical bodies
because we had four very
different body types,
and you know, how
far, how long does it
take for you to get really
cold and start shivering.
Shivering is a really
good thing, actually.
It's our normal
response to the cold.
But when you stop
shivering, that's dangerous.
So when you get to that
point, you know, you
start to become hypothermic.
Very, very dangerous
place to be.
So we-- somebody's
idea of a joke
was to put a beach
chair in an ice chamber,
like a room, that was 5
degrees, and electrodes
all over our body to measure
our body temperature.
And we'd had to try to--
dexterity.
You just stop
functioning in the cold.
You all know that, right?
Although you live
in a beautiful place
and it's warm all
the time, I know
you are out there doing
things in the cold, too.
So just knowing all
of this beforehand
is very helpful for us
in terms of food planning
and what kind of
gear we're going
to use on a trip like this.
So I'm sharing this,
which is coined by a man
by the name of Paul Petzoldt.
He's the founder of NOLS, the
National Outdoor Leadership
School.
And he's coined-- he came up
with this expedition behavior.
And I like this because
it's the kind of way
of thinking that makes
sure that you absolutely
take responsibility
and care of yourself,
but then in doing that, you are
then able to have the group's
care in mind.
You know what I mean?
So it's all about
the collective.
I think if every
company operated
with expedition behavior,
wouldn't we be all better off?
I'm sure you do it here, but
this was an important thing
for us on the expedition
to have or to adopt
as sort of how we
treat one another,
although it didn't
always happen.
I am going to
share a video clip,
and this clip is just me joining
the expedition because that's
a story in itself.
I had six months to prepare
for this expedition,
unlike the others where
they had two or three
years, or four years.
So a little-- we'll roll
the video clip on this.
Thanks.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The newly-formed team trains
for two months in Greenland.
The test is dramatic.
Their camping stoves used
to heat food and melt snow
don't work.
A language barrier results in
delivery of the wrong fuel.
While awaiting delivery
of the proper fuel,
the team eats five days' worth
of rations without leaving.
Once in route, they learn
to ski using parachutes
and to survive when
snowstorms bury their tents.
Ann develops frostbite.
Sarah Harrison struggles
with intestinal problems
as her weight
plummets to 90 pounds.
Towards the end,
the women run out
of food and resort to
eating their frozen garbage.
Greenland is severe,
Antarctica even more so.
- When we get across
Greenland, finally, and feeling
very triumphant and feeling
very solid as a team,
the four of us--
and of course, this is
our dress rehearsal.
This is the stepping
stone to Antarctica.
And Sarah makes the decision
before we leave Greenland
that she, in her words,
as I recall it, says,
I don't have Antarctica
in me any longer.
And I need to step aside.
- And I am--
at that time, had
obviously not entertained
going across the Antarctic,
but the idea of something big
was in my realm of thinking.
- And Sunniva hadn't been
on a lot of expeditions,
and Sunniva was younger than
the rest of us by a fair bit,
at 30 years of age.
And so that young, almost naive
spark was really captivating.
- Supposed to talk?
I had my own little wish,
and that was essentially
to prove that I could do this.
- Sunniva Sorby
is from San Diego.
She has extensive
wilderness trek experience,
although none on expeditions
that are four-months long.
She has only six months to train
before departure, none of it
on the ice.
- She had a willingness to
try anything new about it
and brought no preconceived
conceptions or misconceptions
about what was going on.
I mean, that was her strength,
and that was her weakness.
- And yet, she had the
ability and the hunger
to want to continue to learn.
- This will be a hard
trip for me physically.
I knew that it would be
hard for me mentally.
But I knew that it wouldn't be
so hard that it would break me.
- So she became our fourth.
[END PLAYBACK]
SUNNIVA SORBY: [LAUGHS]
I'll be honest, it broke me.
It's funny, I often
get asked, how did
you think you could do this?
Because there's a little bit
of the ego at play, you know,
when we make a decision
to do something
we've never done before.
It can be a very healthy thing.
But then when you start
on a trip like this,
you must check your
ego at the door.
And it was the ultimate
hero's journey.
I know Joseph Campbell, if any
of you read works from him,
it's the ultimate hero's
journey to find yourself
going all the way
around a circle
and coming back home to
starting-- coming back
to the place you
started from only
to find yourself completely
changed by the experience.
And this was the experience
that I had down there.
It was very physical.
I was the youngest of the
four of us on the team.
But I like to say
that I had-- what
I had going on for me was
that I knew that I absolutely
would not give up.
I would not quit.
I'm Norwegian, after
all, and Norwegians are
known to be a little stubborn.
This can be a
positive trait, and it
was, for the most part,
a very important trait
for me to have on
the expedition.
So we know that we're leaving
a world of comforts and knowns
behind.
Nothing growing
in the Antarctic--
it's a frozen desert.
There is nothing-- you
will see no wildlife
in the actual interior of the
Antarctic continent, no running
water.
But you've got 70% of the
world's fresh water frozen
in the ice sheet, which is one
to three-miles thick from one
point to another.
And we're skiing over at
1.3 miles thick of ice.
It's just hard to wrap
your head around that.
So and all the things
that you're familiar with,
even people, even
roadsigns, none
of that will be experienced
in the Antarctic.
Instead, you're going
to a place where
all the extremes are-- wind.
It's 24 hours of sunlight
when we're going there, from--
we left in November, and
we finished in January.
So that far south,
there's 20-- there's
one sunset and one
sunrise every year.
Isn't that hard to imagine?
And it's so powerful,
the sun is so powerful
when it comes down at--
when-- 100% of the rays come
down, 80% of the sun's rays
are reflected back off
the Antarctic ice sheet,
and that is kind of dangerous.
Because when you're
skiing, and you're me,
and you have bronchitis,
and you're just
having so much
trouble breathing,
I burnt the roof of my mouth
from skiing, from [BREATHES]
this.
It's so dangerous.
It's the single-most dangerous
thing is the wind and the sun,
actually, down there.
So with six months
of preparation--
I was living in San
Diego at the time--
what do you do to take
care of yourself and train?
Well, there's not much I
could do above and beyond what
I was already training
for, which was--
I ran quite a few marathons.
So I would put
rocks in a backpack,
and I would pull three
tires off my Subaru
with chain link around it.
And I would have
a backpack, and I
would have the rope connect here
with carabiners, the same way
my sled would be attached.
And I would just pull
those tires across the dirt
and with rocks and a heavy load
mostly to train physically.
But I think the most
important thing is
what's happening to your mind.
You get bored really quickly
doing something like this.
So I remember this guy--
this is in Penasquitos Canyon.
He came up to me, and
he's on his mountain bike.
And he comes sliding
in like this,
and [MAKES BRAKING NOISE] you
know, a little dust comes up.
And he says, hey,
lady, those tires
roll a lot better
up on their end.
I'm like, thanks, you know.
[LAUGHS] So we put up
with all sorts of things
when we're getting
ready for these trips,
because they're so far away
from our normal, everyday life.
And you start asking yourself
questions like, who am I?
Where did I-- why is this
something that I am consumed
by as something I'd like to do?
It just takes over your
entire physical being,
where you're in that state of
flow, if you know what I mean.
And I started
looking at my family
and looking at, poring
over old pictures,
and trying to understand, am I
really different from my sister
and my two brothers?
And what are the--
all of these questions.
And I find this
photo of my mother.
My father was a captain
on an oil tanker,
and my mother was a
wireless operator on a ship.
And I found this photo of me.
Guess what I'm
holding-- a suitcase.
Of course, I've had
a life of travel.
And next to me is my sister
holding a little baby,
and she's the one with the son.
So I'm like, oh
boy, OK, if you want
to know how you're
going to end up, just
look at some early photos.
And I also found a photo of
my great-grandmother pulling
something.
I thought, OK, that's
definitely running in my family,
because pulling a
sled is not something
that you'd normally do, right?
So here we are in Punta Arenas.
We fly over the
Transantarctic Mountain range.
Finally after two weeks, we
land there on a blue ice runway.
This was the scariest
part of starting the trip.
It's a suncup blue ice runway.
The plane comes down.
It was a DC-9.
And it has to whip
around 180 degrees
to slow down to come back.
And I remember Bruce, the
pilot, his wife was on board,
and she was so, so special.
She made a point of putting
her hand on my shoulder.
And she just said
to me, she goes,
Sunniva when you
get off the plane
and you put your first
step on the continent, just
stand there for a second.
Just let the place take you.
And that was a really,
really powerful thing for her
to share, because
we're all stressed.
We've lost two weeks
to bad weather.
Our cheese has gone moldy.
We've got five guys standing
at the South Pole arm in arm--
they're literally standing
there smoking cigarettes--
and looking at the four of
us coming off the plane.
And they said, let us know
when you want to get picked up.
Thank you.
Right?
From the get-go, the--
people had trouble wrapping
their minds around the fact
that women were
going to do something
in a, up until that point, a
male-dominated environment.
And to look at us,
we're not-- you
know, no disrespect to
anybody from Russia--
but we didn't look like
the Russians shot-putters.
We weren't big and burly.
We were normal women
with fires in our belly
and a desire to do something
not just individually,
but collectively,
and show people
that as humans and as women,
regardless of your gender,
your race, your size, any of
that, you put your mind to it,
anything's possible.
So we wanted to be those
conduits for that message
in the world technically.
So we started skiing.
And we didn't take to heart
with those five guys shared.
And we just start
skiing, one step
at a time pulling our load.
Unfortunately for us, we
had prevailing headwinds.
That was a very unusual
wind year in Antarctica.
Because we hoped to use sails.
We had kites, and if you have
a tailwind, you're skiing.
Your sleds behind you,
and you're on skis,
and you're able to
use a kite and just
sail across Antarctica.
Doesn't that sound fun?
And it sounded so
much fun to us too,
but we, unfortunately, let 10
pounds of sails sat on our sled
the whole trip because of
the headwind that was coming.
So we didn't get to use that,
so we had to pull our load.
And it was really a process of--
we read all these books
about living in the moment.
And it's hard to understand
what that is, because the second
you do it, the moment's gone.
You know?
Have you been there?
[LAUGHS]
So I liken what I did
on this expedition
to absolutely forcing
you to be in the moment,
because if you obsess over where
you are and how big the trip is
and what you're going to
do, you will be absolutely
defeating yourself just
by your own thoughts.
And those thoughts start to
permeate inside your body.
And then all of a sudden,
it impacts your energy,
and then you can't
make that next step.
So it was really,
really important
for us to think one step, one
pole plant, one step, one pole
plant every single day.
And this woman right
here, Sue Giller--
I'm just going to
share a video clip
in a second-- she was our
navigator on the expedition.
We all had different roles.
And her job was to keep us on a
straight path towards the South
Pole.
That sounds simple, right?
We're in a place where
it's absolutely nothing
but white around us,
but we have nothing--
360 degrees-- nothing to
give us a point of reference
for where we are, nothing.
So we're relying on
our compass, which
I'll show you in a second.
But we're relying on a
GPS at night, which Sue--
we always knew when she was
warming up the battery pack
in here, because she screamed.
And she'd warm up the batteries.
And then we'd hold
up the GPS, so we
could latitude,
longitude, and get
a fix for where we are and
then plot that on a map.
So we would know what direction
of travel to take the next day.
So I'll share a
little video clip
of kind of what it was
like to tent with Sue.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Because we had four
distinct personalities,
it really shook things up.
I mean, everybody
had a different sort
of sense of humor, different
times when they would shine,
different times when they
would be compassionate.
Changes within the
group personality
that happened naturally
with four different people
make a huge difference
in your overall outlook
of what you're doing.
- So Anne, today is day number?
- Four, I think.
- [LAUGHS]
- Yeah, it's day four, and we're
already doing mini repairs.
- Isn't it day three?
- Three?
- You're one behind, Sorby.
- Oh.
- I'll have to show you
my other thing I did here.
- Getting dropped off
the ice counts as one.
- OK.
- I got my hat so it fits
more snugly around my face.
Three?
- I'm on the cycle.
This is one of those bad days.
And Sunniva, who had
the least experience
and was the youngest on
the trip says, well, it
doesn't have to be that way.
And I'm sitting there
going, she's right.
You know, this is something
I have control over.
I don't have to sit here
and say, geez, this sucks.
It's one of my down days.
I can throw this
away and let it go.
In retrospect, I'm really
impressed that Sunniva was--
had the insight to see
this, given her, in essence,
lack of experience in this
sort of thing and her youth.
[END PLAYBACK]
SUNNIVA SORBY: I shared that
because I'm tenting with Sue.
And she was-- we're two
introverts and two extroverts
on the expedition.
Can you guess what I am?
[GIGGLES] And Sue was a
computer programmer at the time.
And very literally,
I'm in the tent--
this is the first tent
rotation, the first eight
days on the expedition.
And I am obsessed with
the end of the trip.
Has that ever
happened to, where you
start something and
all you can think about
is the end of the
marathon where you
get to have that cold beer
or something, you know?
All I obsessed was with the end.
And it was very,
very dangerous, and I
didn't know how to
package it and how
to actually, in my mind,
how to keep myself going.
It was really scary.
So I asked Sue.
I said, how do you,
as a mountaineer
and as a computer programmer,
how do you deal with your day
to day to keep yourself going?
And she whipped her
head around very quickly
and she said, well it's easy.
And I thought I was going to
have like the golden answer.
And she goes, I have one good
day, and I have one bad day.
And that's what she said.
And I looked at
her, and I thought,
that sounds
absolutely ridiculous.
What if you have two
good days in a row?
And she-- it was
very, very funny.
She looks at me, and she
goes, well, you're right.
I could actually have
two good days in a row.
So it changed her way
of thinking on the trip.
And she actually had a lot
more energy and kept going.
It was really, really
an interesting thing.
So I shared a little bit about
getting to the South Pole
and how we navigate.
If you're in a complete
whiteout, which
we had quite a lot, this is
an amazing little contraption.
This is how like unevolved
we were back then.
This is a knee pad,
which you know,
anybody who's doing any
masonry work or anything like--
that's a knee pad;
an L-bracket--
a friend of mine
made this for me;
and I've got a
compass right here.
And she created it so that
it had leather on the bottom,
and I could slide it right
here on the L-bracket.
Whoops.
And this is what we had around
our waist the entire time.
We would rotate
who is in the lead.
Like, if I was leading, it
would be for an hour-and-a-half
staring at the needle and
what direction I'm going at.
And I'd have to keep
on a straight line,
because one degree
of error is 60 miles.
You're off course 60 miles,
that would be a really bad day.
So this was our little lifeline
and super important for us
to have that the whole way.
So food, all of our systems,
our rotation and tents,
putting up a snow wall that
took 45 minutes to build because
of those prevailing headwinds--
everything that we did
was pretty much systematic.
So it was very hard to go out
of that routine for yourself
and help somebody.
I know that sounds silly to say,
but you're in your own space.
You're in your
own survival mode.
And even though you want to help
your teammate, it's hard to do,
because you're hunkered down.
You're in that
spot of just trying
to control your own thoughts.
We share this slide for
the University of Minnesota
who was doing a study
on communication.
And we're like, not
much communication
on the expedition for us.
Because we're
sitting on our sleds.
We take a 15-minute
break for lunch.
And we're eating
toffee and GORP--
good old raisins, peanuts--
cheese sticks, anything that
has a high calorie content.
And we're snacking all day.
We're-- have a warm breakfast
and snacking all day long,
every time we take a break.
And then we've got a
warm meal at dinner.
So it was eating cold food,
nothing really exciting,
nothing like the
food that I saw--
that I perused out here, hm-hm.
So you're eating mostly
freeze-dried, dehydrated foods.
And it's amounting to 6,000--
roughly 6,000 calories a person
per day.
It was a lot.
And if you're me, I lost my
appetite about three weeks
into the expedition,
because I was eating--
I was in charge of first
aid and our research.
And I was the one who was
in the first aid kit almost
all the time.
Because I had bronchitis.
And I was using
ibuprofen for my ankles,
which were extremely swollen.
And I was having a
really, really hard time.
And I had systemic edema
where my body was so swollen
that my eyes were swollen shut
when I woke up in the morning.
And I had a day-- and
it was December 24--
where I put my ski poles up in
the air, and I crossed them.
And when you do that, you're
telling your teammates,
I'm done.
I can't go on anymore.
I stopped.
And I stopped because
I was just so, so sick.
And more than the physical
part that shut down,
my spirit just was
crushed, squashed.
And I had nothing
left to think about.
I had nothing left to
actually keep me going.
So I'll share a little
clip about that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- During the trek,
AWE participates
in an ongoing study for the
University of Minnesota.
The topic-- the
psychological effects
of stress, risk, and gender.
- So there were
questions that we
filled out every single night.
And those questions
were something
like, how did you cope today?
And coping mechanisms
were like 1 to 10--
praying, crying, writing.
And how often do
you do this, Anne?
- I to do this every night
generally before I go to bed.
Probably takes five minutes.
Takes Sue about two.
[GIGGLES]
- Can you read off just two
questions from there for me?
- They're asking what
the exertion of the day
was, and it goes from nothing at
all to maximal, which is a 10--
very, very strong.
Generally for me, I'm at
around the five or six range.
- Do you like doing
the questionnaire?
- I tend to get a bit irritable
about it in the evening,
especially after a 12-hour day.
- And that's usually
when you have to do it is
in the evening, right,
after your 12-hour day?
- Yup.
It's after the day.
- Is there a spot on
there for irritable?
- There is.
There's a spot for
irritable, hostile--
sometimes it makes us
hostile [GIGGLES] to do this.
- But I couldn't fight anymore.
I couldn't keep being
obsessed with the pain
and taking painkillers and
having the swelling go down.
I didn't have any more
things to draw from.
And so I let myself cry.
I just sobbed horribly.
And what's nice
out there is you've
got these big glasses
on, and nobody can really
see if you're crying.
So I did it with the-- in
the comfort of the Antarctic.
- You must never
let yourself think
of that big distance, the
enormous distance ahead and all
the pain which lies ahead,
because you might not be
able to cope with big thoughts.
So you just think of
the next 10 minutes.
- There were times when I
prayed for guidance of decisions
when we were making
big decisions
and when I was making
big decisions, guidance
in how to motivate the gang.
[END PLAYBACK]
SUNNIVA SORBY: That was
Sir Ranulph Fiennes.
I told you about the
two men that were
doing the starvations study.
He was one of the two.
So we are now four days
away from the South Pole.
And we are-- Ann is in the lead,
and she's navigating with the--
my friend made one for her too.
She's navigating
off of what she sees
in the distance as something
that's in her straight line.
The problem was that this
particular thing was moving.
And if you're in a plane
and you're flying above us,
this is what we look
like from the air--
the four of us, our two
tents, and our four sleds.
We only got this photo when we
came back from the expedition.
And does that not
look like the moon?
I think that is just what
I would imagine the moon
to look like.
So Ann was navigating off
of a moving object, which
was a C-130 Hercules that came
from McMurdo to the South Pole,
and they heard that
the women were coming.
So they came from
the South Pole.
They flew over us,
and they did this--
tipped the wing.
And we're standing there.
I mean, we have
gone two months not
seeing a soul, not-- nothing.
We've gone so far away
inside, so deep inside.
And I'm really still
very, very sick.
And I stand there-- we all
stand there with our ski poles
under our armpits,
and we're looking
at this plane going, wow.
Like, movement-- there's
movement in the sky.
And there's a plane.
And do they know we're here?
And all these questions--
and then all of a sudden,
there's a chute-- there's a
technical name for the chute
in the back of the plane--
out comes a box.
[MAKES DESCENDING NOISE] Lands
about 150 feet away from us.
So we send our best
skier, Anne Dal Vera,
to go and get the box.
And she comes, and
we rip it open.
It's got Priority Post--
US Priority Post-- love this--
and duct tape.
And there's a letter
in there from 16 people
that are onboard the plane.
And it says, to the
Antarctic explorers,
we have been tracking
you every day.
They knew what our radio sched
time was and our frequency.
And they listened in.
They knew that we had
frostbite, tendinitis.
They knew that I was
so sick, and they knew
that we ran out of chocolate.
And so they said,
congratulations
on reaching the South Pole.
We'll see you when
you get there.
And inside were cheddar
cheese goldfish--
I love those things--
crossword puzzles, comic
strips, all the things
that you might need to
keep yourself a little
entertained out there,
and then lots of food.
There was homemade
chocolate chip cookies.
And the thing after
two months of doing
this and the four
of us overcoming
all sorts of obstacles both
from people who didn't believe
that we could do it, all
the biases and hurdles
you can imagine, we're standing
there, and we're weeping.
The four of us are
around the box,
and we're weeping at
the sight of a red
rose which was in the box.
And it was beautiful, and
it smelled like a rose.
And it was the only
external smell or thing
that we had to remind us
that we-- emotionally, we
were still alive.
And I think that's
an important thing,
because we do these trips to
learn things about ourselves,
yes, and to actually find that
ultimate human experience where
we're in that state of flow
and-- even through hardship.
And so I had a really strong
purpose on this expedition.
And I share this--
I love Victor Frankl's book,
"Man's Search for Meaning"--
really great read, because
essentially, I think all of us
are looking to be happy in life.
It's been written about so much.
And I think happiness
comes from us having
that optimal human experience.
And for me, it's
when I'm engaged
in something physical that
has a meaning to it that's
far bigger than me,
which was the expedition.
We came back from the trip.
We arrived at the South
Pole January 14, 1993.
I'll end with a short little
video clip in a second.
But we got there,
and the best part
about arriving at the
South Pole was not--
it was sort of anti-climactic.
It was over.
It was done.
And that actually was a
hard thing, to be over.
Because every day, you're
focused on survival,
and now, you don't have to be.
So they opened up the
restaurant, the galley for us,
and we had three hours of--
let me tell you,
this was heaven.
We had three hours of nonstop
eating at the South Pole,
because we were so hungry.
It was the end of a day.
We touched the brass
plate at the South Pole,
and this is video
footage from that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Day 43.
We changed tentmates.
- Morning.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Anne is with Sunniva
and is back on track.
Anne led three times today
and is walking normal
and is talkative,
right on schedule.
One comes up, the
other goes down,
and I don't care, as
long as we keep moving.
Day 44-- the ankle is
definitely aggravated
by the weight and climb.
I can't change the uphill,
but I can change the weight.
I tell her there are
different types of weight--
sled weight, emotional weight.
She keeps Sue and Anne going,
and I need her for that.
And it takes energy.
I would be out with
the radio, you know,
and everybody would
have already had dinner.
And I'm still
stringing the antenna.
And if she was my tentmate,
it would never fail.
I would come crawling into
the tent cold and miserable
and sort of feeling
sorry for myself,
and there'd be a
cup of hot soup.
You know, she always did
that, and the others did not,
myself included.
We were in our
hunkered-down survival mode.
You know, you can
get it yourself.
[GIGGLES]
- I mean, it became very
spiritual in a sense,
because you know, when things
happen to you physically,
you don't have control.
And so it becomes
bigger than you are.
And when you let go, I
think the process of change
starts to happen in you.
And you see things differently.
You allow yourself to grow.
But what I didn't realize
was that me being changed
would be through all this pain.
- As we get closer, we begin
to realize what looks like
a little tent is actually a
three or four-story building.
You have no
perspective whatsoever.
At one level, I was
absolutely ecstatic,
because as the navigator,
I'd found the South
Pole in the middle of nowhere.
- And I first hear
the noise, and then I
see the figure of
the snowmobile.
And then, I smell the diesel.
And so you talk about your
senses being reawakened.
- There were three people
on snowmobile coming out
to greet us, and we were amazed.
- There were people there.
- Wow.
[GIGGLES] This is a big event.
- And so these
people filtered out
of these building,
this research station.
And they came, and they
were cheering us on.
- We were very much,
I think, like horses
heading for the barn.
I mean, we just started
going faster and faster.
- All of a sudden, you weren't
in control of your thoughts
anymore.
You just had to let
things happen to you.
- This is taking us a while
to sort of plod our way
to the pole, the visual pole.
We're seeing it.
We're going there.
At this point, I've got the
group shoulder to shoulder,
because I want us to come in
together to signify this team.
- And these people come out.
And they're shaking your hand.
And they're just so
excited, and we've
got to to be the first people
to come out and meet you guys.
This is just the neatest thing.
- And they're walking with us.
It's almost like a parade.
People are cheering
on the sidelines.
And they're telling us,
you know, yay for women.
- Good job.
[GIGGLES] Glad you're here.
And congratulations.
We all touched the
pole marker together.
[INSPIRING MUSIC]
- There is no
evidence any longer.
I mean, if you look at Sunniva's
face, you do not see pain,
and we're not rushing her
off to some medical facility.
We are reveling in the fact
that we are there, just
by the mere dint that
we were standing there
for so long freezing to death.
[INSPIRING MUSIC]
[END PLAYBACK]
SUNNIVA SORBY: Arrived
there at the pole,
and it was minus 76 degrees.
And we were picked up there.
Took us three days to get
away from the South Pole
back to Patriot Hills,
because the weather was bad,
so like a theme running through.
And then we get
to Patriot Hills,
and we're flown
back to Minnesota,
where a throng of young
kids were there to greet us.
The best part with that was
that they all had these flowers,
these carnations
that they were given.
And all the heads-- by
the time they got to us,
all the heads had
been chopped off,
because-- making
their-- making their way
through the sea of people.
But it was amazing expedition.
And I have gone
down there, as he--
James mentioned, 50 times
with Polar Latitudes--
not just with Polar Latitudes,
but we operate ships
down there as well.
So I'm going to end
with this, and I
want to take some questions.
And I'm sorry if I
ran a little bit over.
It's all good, but
we've got minutes.
And does anyone have
any questions for me?
Yeah.
There's a mic there
if you'd like.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
why you need four people.
Like, do they go in
like different numbers,
or do you always
need four people?
SUNNIVA SORBY:
Ah, good question.
Why four?
So it was a logistics
scenario for us.
They did have five women
join the trip at one point,
and the alumni list
was quite long.
People couldn't stay connected
to it because of family
obligations or things.
And it was a project that
took five years to pull off.
So they wanted four
so that we could
have two tents and two
people in each tent
and then have our food bags
be, you know, 32 pounds
and rotate that way.
So it was really a
logistical thing.
Thanks for asking.
Yeah.
Anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How did
you meet each other,
like on the phone [INAUDIBLE]?
SUNNIVA SORBY: How did
we meet each other?
I didn't know the three of them,
but they had met each other
through the outdoor community.
It's kind of a small
community in certain circles.
My friend at the
time was writing
an article on this expedition.
And she learned
from Ann Bancroft
in one of the phone
calls that they exchanged
that Sarah had dropped out.
And so my friend Deborah told
me, you should contact them.
And I thought, no.
I mean, that's the major league.
I was in the minor league.
But I made the phone call.
I picked up the phone, and
I left a voicemail for Ann.
I didn't hear from
her for two weeks,
and then she called me back.
And that's how-- how
I got to meet them.
And then I met
them on the phone,
was interviewed,
flew to Minnesota,
and I had three days of
very deep self-analysis
and inventory around
who I am, what
am I capable of
doing, what am I not,
and being really honest
about all of that with them.
And then, they picked
me as the fourth.
Yeah.
Bless you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SUNNIVA SORBY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: For
those of us who are
interested in going
to Antarctica--
not at all on an expedition
with the scope of what you did
but just to visit and
see some amazing animals
and wildlife-- are there
any programs specifically
that you recommend?
SUNNIVA SORBY: Yeah, absolutely.
And I hope you
don't do what I did.
There's a different way
to travel down there
and expedition cruise ships.
I feel like I am so lucky, and
I feel very, very fortunate
I get to work with a company
called Polar Latitudes,
and we operate 200-plus
passenger expedition ships.
And we have-- that's all we do.
From October until
March, we go down there.
And it is a really--
a fascinating way to
experience Antarctica,
because you're-- it's a rite of
passage to go along the Drake,
or through the Drake.
And then slowly,
Antarctica is being
revealed in all its glory.
So the season is from
October until March.
Lots of operators
down there, but--
everybody likes to say they have
the best team on the planet,
but I think we do.
And part of that
is our experience.
We're safe.
When I'm down there,
I'm a historian onboard,
and I drive a Zodiac.
And we do citizen science.
We're collecting
data for researchers
at Scripps, for example, and
Woods Hole in Massachusetts.
Because there are a
lot of people globally
that are interested in what's
happening with climate change.
And so we are, as an
operator, with all
of those days in Antarctica,
we have an opportunity
to collect data every
day for science.
And so it's a program we do on
every single one of our trips.
And it's the thing that
makes me really proud
to be aligned with
Polar Latitudes,
because we have to stay
relevant in today's world.
Because things are changing,
and people want to do something,
and they don't know how.
So by engaging in
this, they're actually
assisting the researchers that
are stuck in their office.
So it's pretty cool.
Join us.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SUNNIVA SORBY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So when you do
something extreme like this,
and you are injured
during the trip,
and you're taking
medication, you're
working through the
pain, how do you
know when it's time to
quit or not to quit?
When I look at your
ankle like that,
I think I would be
scared about whether I
could walk normally or run
again after I finished the trip.
I imagine something like
that-- this probably
happened during training too.
You probably had injury
you had to work through.
So I was just
wondering, how do you
make that decision, when it's OK
to keep going and when to stop?
SUNNIVA SORBY: That is
a very good question.
Thank you for asking me that.
And that is a tough
one, because we--
our ego-- this is where the
ego is not a helpful thing
on an expedition.
There's a part of
us that that wants
to overcome everything
and complete something
at all costs.
That's the ego at work.
And then there's the
reality of how we really are
and how far we can go.
And can we realign and
readjust the needle
to say that, no, this
is actually success
and be OK with that?
It's a really hard thing
for all of us humans.
On this particular trip
for me, I was scared.
I was scared a lot, and I had
no one to talk to about it.
I had no one to--
I had nothing.
[LAUGHS] I couldn't Google.
I couldn't get online
and ask, at what
point-- how much
ibuprofen is going
to eat up my stomach lining?
Which happened, and
that's why I didn't--
I wasn't hungry.
I lost my appetite.
So it's like that slowly, that
spiral downhill happens quickly
into that dark abyss.
So I had to be really
honest with myself first.
And that was hard for me.
It took me until December 24.
Our expedition
ended on January 14.
So for that entire time,
guess what I'm doing.
Struggling, fighting myself.
Why?
You know, we do this.
We all do it.
And I got to a place where
I couldn't fight anymore.
Very literally, I had
no fight left in me.
I had no-- nothing--
I had-- I was empty.
And this, being empty
up here, scared me most.
And when I got to that
place of being very, very
empty with nothing to feed
myself, I surrendered.
And what that looks like is just
the ultimate three days' worth
of bawling my eyes
out in the Antarctic.
And I'm Norwegian, and
we're kind of proud people.
And we don't do that, so just
to give you some insight.
And that was a very
freeing experience for me.
And when I cried and I
let it all rip like that,
I was embraced by Antarctica.
I actually allowed myself
the space and the time
to give it all up, let go,
detach from the outcome.
Be in the moment.
Allow yourself the
opportunity to be helped
by something bigger than you.
That's where the spiritual part
of the trip happens for me.
And so when I got to that place
and I allowed other things
to show up for me--
and it was that little ice
crystal over there that
happened to catch my attention.
It was a little tiny--
the minute I became aware of
something other than my pain
and my suffering, phew, the
whole world opened up for me.
So it was a very, very--
I think it's super
important for us
to give ourselves permission
to go to the edge.
Because I think that we're
often afraid to go to the edge,
because it's going to hurt me.
We don't know this.
And we're stronger for it.
I used to think that strength
was physical strength, somebody
reaching the top of a
summit by themselves
or skiing across the
South Pole by yourself.
But strength is
really our willingness
to admit a weakness.
That's what I believe.
And the second we're
willing to admit
that we're less than
who we thought we are,
I think we give room and
space to other things coming
into the purview and
making us stronger.
I know that's a
sideways answer for you,
but I hope it does
answer your question.
Because it was a very
much an internal decision
I had to make.
I could have very easily
said, ladies, I'm stopping.
I want an-- I want a heli--
I want an airlift
out of here now.
And it would have taken three
days for me to get help.
But I was too proud to do
that, and I was too committed
to the team experience.
So I pushed harder and to the
edge every minute and every day
just to keep it all together.
And I think we're capable of
much more than we think we are.
I hope that answers
your question.
Thanks.
Anybody else?
Well, thank you guys for coming.
Yeah, I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys and gals.
So that's how I spent
my summer vacation.
[LAUGHS] I really appreciate
you taking the time
and coming in to
listen to this today.
And so go out there and
make some magic happen.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]